Undercover Boss is an incredibly popular
CBS reality show featuring CEOs or other
high-ranking executives donning
disguises to work at the lowest levels
in their organization all in an effort
to become better bosses and make the
workplace a better place with eight
seasons and more than 100 episodes
there's plenty of trivia out there about
the show and it's masked managers but
the show's biggest fans have likely
heard it all before so here's some
obscure Undercover Boss facts for the
die-hard
undercover inspiration it was while
watching the real-life PR disaster of
the opening of British Airways Terminal
5 at Heathrow Airport in London in 2008
that British reality TV producer Stephen
Lambert had a brilliant idea
according to Lambert's book Undercover
Boss inside the TV phenomenon that is
changing bosses and employees everywhere
the kernel of the concept for the show
came from British Airways head honcho
Willie Walsh's response to a reporter's
question about whether he'd suffered
travelling inconveniences using the very
airline he runs he responded I can't
because people in ba recognise me that
simple truth led Lambert to pitch the
idea to channel 4 and the first series
aired in 2009 Lambert and executive
producer Elie Holtzman were then able to
bring the show to CBS in 2010 and make
it the American reality TV juggernaut it
is today with one interesting difference
in the British version after the
emotional one on once the boss never
revealed the ruse in front of the entire
company via a celebration screening of
clips from the episode Boltzmann said he
thought Americans would want a big
celebration and the companies involved
have confirmed that to be true superstar
the show's biggest fans know it's been a
smash since the very beginning the first
episode of Undercover Boss in 2010
followed Super Bowl 44 giving it the
best possible lead-in and while many
shows have still failed in the spot
Undercover Boss thrived retaining an
astounding 38 point six million viewers
for its debut one word and that's just
unbelievable even after it moved to its
regular 9:00 p.m. Sunday night slot it
still averaged 17 million viewers per
episode in its first season making it
the most popular new show of the
2009-2010 television season mayor gets
mired Pittsburgh Mayor Bill Peduto found
himself at the center of a controversy
that he categorized it's sublime
Vickey lessness when county controller
chelsa wagner refused to release
taxpayer funds to a tourist organization
that offered to donate some of the prize
money awarded to the city workers
featured on the show you're going to be
getting a check $20,000 for the down
payment and the ability to purchase oh
my god oh my goal prior to the episode
mayor Peduto promised that no public
funds would go towards the prizes but
then visit Pittsburg an organization
largely funded with taxpayer dollars
agreed to donate fifty thousand of the
one hundred fifty five thousand dollars
he pledged to help for needy workers
this prompted Wagner to withhold all
taxpayer funds from visit Pittsburgh
sparking a mini controversy that died
down a week later when visit Pittsburgh
clarified that their donations came from
their general fund which is a mix of
public and private dollars
Wagner released the funds but vowed
further action if it could be proven
that tax dollars were in fact used
Peduto had this to say on the matter
some people want to use this as an
opportunity as a battering ram I think
it's the first time that any politician
has ever been accused for lining someone
else's pockets under cover aftermath one
year after house flipper turned seminar
guru Armando Montelongo episode aired
over 150 former students of his seminars
filed a class action lawsuit against it
their suit alleges that the former flip
this house host seminar course which
purports to instruct people on how to
get paid to flip houses is a lie and
their widespread promotion of that lie
violates federal racketeering laws among
the accusations are bizarre claims that
Montelongo studied a film about
mind-control cults and used it to
develop his programs and that advanced
programs costing participants up to
fifty four thousand dollars are nothing
more than schemes to get participants to
keep buying additional seminar products
Montelongo has refuted the allegations
telling In Touch Weekly that his
participants in the lawsuit are people
who decided that continuous hard work is
not for them he also claims that some of
them have started rival seminars and are
colluding to come together to try to
bring down number one thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all the school stuff we know
you love to
you
[Applause]